citizens of the reject Nation welcome to another
of our DC animated films this one actually
in the dcau as far as I know John and I are
confused one day it's gonna make sense as
told by you how you feeling John I am super
excited I'm ready to get wet how are you going
I am ready to get turgid wet and Aquaman uh
neither of us have seen this one nope this
is our first that's gonna be a theme across
all these reactions you may have caught on
our intros we haven't seen this no First Watch
it's an
it's an in the order of the dcau so if you'd
like to watch more of these please do subscribe
hit that notification Bell leave a comment
let us know which of these you've enjoyed
the most which one you want us to watch next
we're going in some sort of order we'll find
out all of us together we think and please
do hit that like button so we know that you
did in fact like this and most of all if you
want to watch this in order with us without
without edits without without gaps we want
to see our resting watching fish's swim face
which looks something like this become a patron
for every moment queued up from the start
to the Finish you know we can't play the actual
movie over there because Warner Brothers we're
not of the brothers we're not Brothers wondering
they can play it we cannot so hit that patreon
if you want to join us for the entire journey
and either way let's kick it off with Throne
of Atlantis
new logo exciting
Aquaman's in the D he's earned it getting
that D getting that day very important for
the throne
deepest trench in the world I think right
I'm a trench expert I mean obviously James
wants the trench ah if only is that your son
big fan of the Justice League yeah he used
to play with a toy submarine I gave him but
not anymore oh World building Dad can't compete
with Heroes like Superman around uh you're
a real hero not all heroes wear capes sonar
has inbounds sir impossible it's open ocean
for Miles computer has 15 no 22 separate inbound
he counts very fast how he got Captain that's
right real heroes do math 37. now 55 inbounds
still on target this guy is really good at
Counting
they look like like what D minus ten like
people engine room report taking water captain
oh oh angry Atlantean Zhang or is this the
trench like the Black Panther story I wonder
if that's what he was gonna adapt could be
oh I wouldn't put past him this is California
with an emergency SOS
oh God what a bad way to go yeah SOS responding
to another SOS drowning plus fear that's like
the worst knowing you're gonna bite at them
drowning yeah avoid the ocean upon shortness
of breath yeah right heart racing and then
boo hey Jim Lee art I think ooh I think it's
Jim Lee art yeah it's definitely Jim Lee art
beautiful work great line work new 52 suit
on the soups different belts no undies outside
the where are the under wherefore art thou
underway is I hope uh James Gunn brings the
undies back I think that'll be a very good
strong visual of uh this hopeful Superman
he said no Origins but uh I do want to see
them for years how he chose those undies I
mean that's the only merch I want shopping
STAR labs that's right that's right this is
Colonel Trevor government liaison of the Justice
League James Cameron's back hey Jimmy Kims
Justice League tested better Justice League
town for the boys there was the super seven
hey not yet cyborg okay continuity is a mess
guys what's happening oh okay I see what this
is nicely done we got Hoodwinked
no please just a little longer five minutes
more oh that's that's sad I came by to see
how you were doing after the operation as
long as I had my brain in heart attack I'll
be all right well I guess I'll check you later
I guess I'll put away my Robo brain and heart
[Laughter] you should keep those you're right
the Navy wants our missiles back I'll boom
down there and check it out myself the others
they don't really come in at all despite what
you would like the world to think Colonel
Trevor there is no justice league oh interesting
second movie already that yeah that disparate
oh great shot with the table too yeah the
empty table the big long shadow you ever feel
alone oh but I've learned a way to deal with
it
watch Man of Steel kiss and float into the
sky which I could probably only safely do
with you yeah all right yeah it's little things
you know yeah it's a good line though oh yeah
I wouldn't be able to resist that come on
now life sucks I've never believed it before
but I believe it now
no hey there's another one over here okay
but I'm cutting you off after this one Arthur
there in the World is Carmen San Diego all
these years all these years just so hunting
down Aquaman
I'm alone we're talking so I know you miss
your dad but oh I was gonna eat that then
you're gonna have to go through me first
I was hoping to fight before dinner let it
warm up hungry oh come on man what these guys
do they're so coordinated hold up hold up
[Music] [Laughter] let's go oh yeah
[Music] oh geez back in the head wow dang
guys are murderers it's pretty cool action
brutal sound design
oh jeez man it's exactly what we've been looking
for David we must confront him tonight maybe
we shouldn't out him here just yet doctor
we can approach him in the morning is that
All-State stand yeah was it Andre Brower or
Dennis Haysbert oh that's the name I was like
it's almost actually turns out it's neither
thanks guys I needed to blow off some steam
yeah steam because you're a water guy [Laughter]
puns
oh cool are we so dense what the hell are
you oh
wish I knew pal is this like Aquaman of Steel
it's learning kind of feel that way right
now it definitely does
cool damn worried about you under all this
water my guy gets Rusty is that a handprinted
oh Eerie what the hell
now
oh no oh
the most damage oh it's all right spiky
ah
whoa they just wheeled boom tubes already
damn you don't take a bunch of water with
you when you do that we didn't see him Landing
though
foreign [Music]
let me walk past my trauma wall here keep
these up to remind me why I punched people
who take lobsters contacted everyone yeah
Billy you came sure these two love this
hey guys sorry um not late I'll bet you like
Cuban food I know this sick place in Cuba
interesting inflection I mean it worked
oh no yeah what's the what I was just about
to seal the deal Cyborg's got something all
hands on deck race here to headquarters
we have a headquarters is that Philly I think
it is yeah he's back Clark yeah this actually
works ah
amazing that oh I adore that oh it takes and
they're nice frames I mean purple go with
her hair it's nice accents this is uh Lois
Lane Diana Prince oh that's some grip I work
with Clark closely oh my Diana is a diplomat
so this is an interview no it's a date it's
a wonder women go out with you at all and
Diana love your glasses thanks
saddle yeah what are they doing here I love
you Shazam oh Shazam fans yeah yeah they did
just materialize in the middle of the street
just very public good thing no one's driving
by well the bat's too good for us now it's
Batman he doesn't answer Hales I got a big
light in the sky yeah he's the most famous
hail of all it's like a signal of sorts scarecrow
don't pay me enough to deal with this [__]
you got that right he needs his own intro
there he is [Laughter] let's go
are you spooky [Music] well glue your schedule
because you and I are [Laughter]
relaxed I got this hey there hinge dudes I'll
be handling your arrest today [Music]
get us out of here yeah Gotham citizens aren't
probably used to Space Magic [Music] wow the
Hot Wheel in the Sky nice
[Laughter]
we're done here are we who's the supplier
for the aerosol component of the fear toxin
what about something simple like where's the
Scarecrow bro I caught them for you're welcome
you want to help do me a favor don't don't
yeah he's got bad business to get into guys
come on sir not appearing in this film no
I'll be in the third act yeah they need him
he'll come back and save the day I count four
dozen unique hand prints moving in sync four
squadrons oh never mind he showed up walk
us through your assault
oh cool the s in my cave is black because
I'm edgy it doesn't match but that's okay
just wanted to pop you know these were warriors
agreed
that looked like it hurt all over again yeah
seriously not the Sound Sensitivity makes
sense sound travels 4.3 times faster underwater
whatever Mr barrel roll do a barrel roll
freeze
[Music] and gills as in mermaids as in Atlantis
where is this
wowie it sunk into the ocean but its people
were saved by the magic of the king's Trident
which turned them irreversibly into creatures
of the sea I believe you of course he does
[Music] Superman and I will go question Dr
Shin what should the rest of us do find Atlantis
you know bring Atlantis to me so far better
portrayals of Superman and Wonder Woman like
from the leap I was about to say yeah I'm
enjoying them so far so good we're about to
strike first and strike quickly my mother
will not see it as such she is yet to grasp
the dangers of the surfaces you have Prince
arm soon she'll have no choice the mutton
chops on orn yeah the the chops run thick
in that Aqua family
she's got so many thingama Bobbers it's like
crayon colored it's cool like I like the texture
of the the whites they kill our race they
poison our oceans we must protect our people
and attack as long as I am queen you will
preserve the peace at all costs oh what of
my other son have you seen Arthur he is not
yet ready for the weight of the crown he will
learn at my side mirror bring him to me at
once you guys got this not too far Arthur
don't fall in I can do it oh merman paw man
[Music]
it's an interesting moment I saw her she left
Arthur and she's not coming back it's just
you and me now son and I'm not going anywhere
and you are schizophrenic we should see a
doctor if you're seeing women in the oceans
I like the way they're doing his story here
though like a whole origin yeah yeah it is
interesting considering the last movie like
Justice League bar Aquaman and now he's getting
like an actual Spotlight yeah the rest of
the team does their thing it's cool yeah I
like it I like the World building call me
after you've made contact congratulations
David I could not have found him without you
I've got an evil jacket on oh that's why oh
no good reveal that was cool payload ready
sir
Reef get Dr Shin and a half breathe my warmest
regards don't be an aqua racist I mean it's
uncomfortable I like how giant his neck is
to balance out the helmet they're like let's
try to make this you know physically sustainable
he does a lot of neck lifting I must talk
to you Mr Curry come back later I'm really
hungry right now and not in a good way how
about your father why did you say that name
no one skips trap day in this universe in
the game
trap City I want to be all traps just I'm
gonna lean enema traps you my boy are the
key to all of my research I'm gonna I'm gonna
let you in because I just can't talk through
a door anymore
oh no hell
it's just to see Playing Tricks on you boy
five assassin men and they did not just Gore
your doors
they fight like fishermen yeah they do
I always feel bad for the lighthouse and every
adaptation right such a beautiful place to
live it's the Bruce's parents of Aquaman Batman
has pearls Superman that says Krypton he loses
the lighthouse yep foreign
houses left so many ships are gonna crash
now because of you guys Arthur Curry is under
my protection by order of Queen Atlanta
[Music]
should turn the water ice maybe cold
oh that's cool [Music] Follow My Lead I am
an investigative reporter you know journalism's
dead
we need to avenge journalism you don't destroy
someone's work and then let them live to recreate
it don't touch anything someone fed these
fish recently
hahaha
that's great Thomas Curry begging Dr Shin
for help with his son Arthur Shin suspects
Curry's son is half Atlantean invoke the emergency
protocol oh no this attack tells us what we
already know surface World wants us dead Perhaps
it is time for our worlds to come together
have Manta arrange a meeting between myself
and this Justice League I will broker a piece
with them in person I hope you make it there
yeah uh your mother met and fell in love with
your father that Union resulted in your birth
she could neither wedge her father nor raise
a halfling child heartbroken she returned
to lead her people it's interesting how close
this was to the movie getting released yeah
similar what is it
this was our King's Royal garb now it is yours
oh my dude hey thanks for that field data
I'm still working on a patch to quiet the
servos Sarah I can't talk right now oh Sarah
it's like your dad come on man coordinates
attached find Arthur Curry fast on it he's
looking for Fairyland
the last suit you'll ever wear armor up I
felt like there was something wrong with me
and now some mermaid comes out of the sea
and tells me my mother is alive and I'm the
future of some Fairyland I've never seen yes
I was waiting for that that's cool um
the trench yes whoa nice can you eat these
guys like you would a fish probably take a
sushi make a little yeah nice little roll
out but they're now in Reverse
that's a curry I'm the Flash
yes wow nice
oh nicely done my man yes
Superman damn Beacon Arthur if I had a
chance to save my world and meet one of my
own race even for a moment that would be enough
let's do this Arthur just makes fun of train
traps go to the gym
king of traps no
it's all I see king of trap Lantus trap cities
about this movie your brother Arthur can Bridge
the peace between Atlantis and the surface
your judgment is compromised you refuse to
attack the surface because you have a son
there a bastard Elder son son you who spelled
Atlantean blood and blamed it on the surface
I see you
get out of my way damn good I am queen and
war is not in my plans yeah I don't like that
close up yeah it was just a matter of time
it is in mine
oh dude [Music] that's gonna fill up the whole
chamber yes the worst way to start so tell
me what you like it's time you found out for
yourself oh [Music] tell me why is the Royal
City deserted our brave men and women have
gone to prepare for war not possible the queen
would never allow this our Queen Is Dead foreign
killed by a surface dweller prove it whoever
did this will pay
welcome bastard
killed her I did
You Can Count yourself fortunate bastard at
least our mother won't be the impediment to
your life that she was to mine ocean real
son of a [__]
what's up
damn
feel my power success
only royalty can wield the magic of the Trident
ah interesting offer them to the horrors of
the dark Trench oh no oh cool all of these
ruins I was like how are they gonna keep them
alive like Green Lantern would drown immediately
ah these little bubbles I mean I was already
wondering like how's Wonder Woman breathing
down here Amazonian I'm like I get the magic
space guy and the Kryptonian guy and cyborg
has his mouth thing but the thing is scary
and I have questions yeah
the cthulhu's the mother of all tidal waves
is heading for the Eastern seaboard is that
Metropolis secondary confirmation oh good
oh good yeah ETA to impact 20 minutes how
are the three of us going to evacuate entire
cities we can't people are going to die oh
no break out your bat tsunami wall or something
that shark repellent can only do so much only
royalty can wield the magic
of the Trident oh come on
[Music] oh buddy rise to your full potential
Cthulhu
oh my God
yeah clearly didn't work out so well immediately
nah soups will come back
whale friendly done nicely done if only James
Cameron had directed A Aquaman film oh if
only how's that joke and Entourage that would
have been so real
yeah Bonk
remodeled the trench you're welcome I talked
to Fish now and they actually listen I'm gonna
stop my evil half brother from destroying
the surface world you want to come it would
be my honor it's an interesting it's very
different like characteristics he just changes
like no I got jokes
oh oh good call
I mean it's a little late I I you guys could
have spotted that a little earlier you had
20 minutes
oh oh oh [Applause]
[Music] he wants his entrance Moses kill the
humans
humans oh boy [Music]
geez
whoa
every time flash it's just it's just so good
yes yeah
just boxes yeah
John Henry irons are we oh oh sweet out of
nowhere let's do this
yep nice what to do still that's fantastic
damn
that's cool Green Lantern power vacuum yes
I just love that he's got a little perch to
sit on it's like Gundam Wing vacuum just vibing
out
Jimmy Olsen's here he's always on the case
but isn't he supposed to be a CIA operative
he's already dead run Jimmy
I would not want to be on her bad side [Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh Megalodon oh we just ate him yup damn that's
how you use those Aquaman powers hahaha
that's that's great all that build up and
then Megalodon this madness form King om traitor
sees her make her watch my Triumph
let us see whose magic is stronger I can see
your Schwartz is his biggest mine damn oh
these are your Guardians this will be easier
than I ever dreamed
oh no
all right kill kill him gotta kill him kill
him
I admire your determination but the Trident
is mine to command wench nah who went way
to throw the winch in there
damn it
you should have done like a Green Lantern
fishnet or the vacuum yeah
oh damn horm can even cook soups we're not
going to win by hitting them as hard as we
can bro do not turn this into a learning moment
he killed his own mother does that help face
me arm yeah come on art step up
pretty good with the bow staff
whoa
oh cyborg oh
come on Victor
do tase me bro Lantern said orm confessed
to killing his mother to us he lied to his
people but you saw it and you know what that
means
he is just good at Goring people he is that
trident is useful Gorham
killed her ideas this I ran the song through
her myself
you did do that villainy wait just deception
is their service magic liar I was there when
Oren boasted to the murder of our Queen I
did this for you you wow nice
you need a light to guide you in the darkness
people of Atlantis
what are you doing becoming a beacon he's
a lighthouse
oh [Music] Bend in the knee [Music] okay just
immediately you're my queen now didn't the
end of the other one have like a threat from
Atlantis I thought it ended with like imma
come for you
seems okay how does it feel it feels good
but we can pick it up tonight over dinner
I'd like that yeah that's what I'm talking
about victory victory yeah and the comic logo
he has found his place are you free later
if I can find my glasses [Music]
we need to consider solidifying this team
like weekly meetings I'm in a man yeah well
online they're calling him oh I hate that
they always do I should keep a foothold in
both worlds besides it'll help repair relations
if I'm seen helping out through that perhaps
perhaps you should stay behind me I'm the
one with the Trident perhaps you should stay
behind me
[Music] oh yeah
[Music]
cool yeah
look at that lineup
not bad I like this much better than the other
uh War One than the Justice League we were
like this a lot that was that was good I did
like this a lot as well I I thought something
you mentioned earlier on the uh the way they
had his story separate and then the Justice
League already formed was really interesting
because they were able to do like a Justice
League Sequel and an Aquaman origin in a way
that didn't feel like the only time I noticed
the everyone fight him at once was the end
but then they were really clever to make it
an intellectual thing like they didn't have
them like because the first movie ends with
let's all team up and unite together had been
really like lackluster if we were like we
were just missing Aquaman like yeah I was
afraid of that but instead they had to be
like they had to outsmart him it was Rosario
Dawson I meant to call it out that's great
uh I I was sitting there a lot of the time
going man I bet I Wonder Woman sounds just
like uh Rosario Dawson so not Michelle Monaghan
this time I guess not yeah so uh yeah like
that really impressed me there was a couple
writing things that that drought drove me
a little crazy uh like there was times where
like they would repeat but in the opposite
direction like like she was like do you really
think the only way to have safety is to kill
everyone you will watch me kill everyone for
the safety I was like why are we like and
and like little things but overall like a
much tighter uh story and I didn't love the
the Superman um like he was he only had like
eight lines and one of them was like oh shove
that fork so far down is like Superman's not
vengeful yeah but otherwise like it was a
better characterization of the two of them
I thought so yeah like that one line yeah
anytime Superman gets like outwardly like
I'm gonna beat the [__] out of you or
something to that extent I'm a little bit
like is that soups but this one definitely
didn't stand out as much as the Justice League
War one where I was like this guy seems like
he had a different guy like most of the time
he seemed like he had his good-natured clarkness
I feel like yeah that that came back yeah
and and I was gonna ask actually like when
they have the date him and Diana and then
Lois shows up like what is the what exactly
is so they really tried to shoehorn in and
they've tried a number of times to have one
Roman and Superman have relationship I think
it's just because like sure they both have
powers so like the when the new 52 launched
they did have them together and I guess that's
like you know piecing together some of that
but it never like works like it it's like
it just doesn't feel right and even here it
kind of doesn't feel like right yeah I mean
I don't know there's something so quintessential
about Clark and Lois and Humanity the humanity
yeah it's like the link to humanity rather
than the link to something you know god-like
yeah I feel like Batman are friends but Jimmy's
his best friend so like making Lois his partner
is as important as Jimmy being the best friend
so if you have that'd be like if his only
friends were Batman and Wonder Woman it kind
of keeps him out of the humanity which is
honestly kind of the Betrayal yeah no I I
can I can see that yeah and it is here and
I I at least appreciated that it wasn't as
extreme to that degree and Wonder Woman as
well like in the Justice League War was a
bit you know it was much like sort of sassier
and edgier than I ever associate Wonder Woman
with I liked here that she when she was a
warrior the Betrayal was like I'm proud of
you for standing up for your plate your people
I will do the same it wasn't like my people
are better I'm gonna be mad like yeah it didn't
feel so like aggro it felt like we are both
Warriors and like I have to do this like there
was an honor to it yeah yeah yeah yeah and
that's that sense of you know slight fish
out of wateriness in that you know you are
a warrior in a human society for the most
part one giant flaw for me sure why oh why
oh why would arms stop the wave from killing
millions of people and then like fight on
the land dwellers terms they could have had
one line of dialogue where he was like I'll
beat you with your own game Bell Rev what
do we got
oh I am a royal blood
at least to give him a pool that's nice you
will let me speak brother
I am Lex Luthor yes you are I have a proposition
for you
I was listed in the voice credits and I wondered
why I didn't notice that's crazy oh that's
really funny yeah but like one line of dialogue
is you know I'll be at your own game the arrogance
form or another line of dialogue is they're
able to thwart the wave but they're still
gonna have to fight but like without even
acknowledging it we build up all this tension
through the second the late second act of
this wave crashing down and then they're like
no and like you just like what yeah and I
get that it's you know big and impressive
and imposing to be like I'm going to part
the seas and demonstrate my control over the
oceans and and yet at the same time I feel
like yeah that does lessen the impact because
you know not everyone's gonna see this a lot
of people have left and if you even say the
arrogance line then that shows the the Splendor
and then also like your own game I'm gonna
War your way land dwellers yeah yeah I can
beat you in the sea and on and on land yeah
and that's something that would be intimidating
if you see someone invading you from their
Turf and like taking you over on yours it's
more likely that you're gonna like give up
yeah so like I just I just I was really bothered
for like five minutes I had to shake it I
was like this is dumb okay we're back yeah
I could see that I mean I guess I guess it
maybe paints you into a corner like how do
they figure out what to do with all the water
but even then I feel like with the the team
like you know if you do flood the city I feel
like the team could still probably figure
out how to undo all that or just don't like
or just have like you know Green Lantern push
it out or just don't yeah but overall like
this felt way more Justice League and also
I really was impressed that it was able to
do something different with the team simultaneously
of Aquaman like that was an impressive tone
to balance like a Justice League 2 an Aquaman
one it didn't feel like you tucked them away
like there were separate missions that didn't
feel like side missions yeah really cool tone
yeah and it felt pretty well-rounded it felt
pretty breathable because I mean this is a
compact movie I mean this is I feel like by
a couple minutes one of the shorter ones we've
seen and it didn't feel like I remember what
I was talking about Justice League War feeling
kind of kind of compacted a little bit like
yeah like there's a bunch of happening and
there's not really a ton of uh meat on the
character bones and whatnot and here I was
sitting there thinking like I glanced at the
at the clock at one point and I was like oh
well like you know I thought we were way further
into this movie than we were in a good way
where I was like oh cool like somehow in an
hour and 10 12 minutes they've still managed
to make this feel you know like paced like
an actual story give it some room to have
those more contemplative moments with Arthur
as you're watching him get on his feet like
I I really loved you could split this movie
in half and you have like a nice gradual adventure
of the Justice League you know figuring out
how and why to come together and addressing
that thing of like yeah they're they're a
team in the public eye but they're not really
a team yet and so watching them sort of grow
as a team on the one side was fun while you
also watch Arthur sort of pick up the wreckage
of his life and find purpose and even hearing
the super seven like I like that there's a
clear Line in the Sand of like we're not a
team we don't see each other two Justice League
is a United Team I really liked how clear
they made that yeah absolutely and nobody
ever likes their given name from the people
I just once I won the next time somebody gets
their their name moment I want them like this
is pretty good
because I'm sure yeah and I like the the voice
cast overall I like that the main cover art
looks like Tom Cruise in the 80s with blonde
hair no that's like Top Gun one Tom Cruise
brows and nose right there and they did a
nice thing uh uh too with that where like
you know he even the little Easter eggy moments
that are uh you know like oh here's how he
gets the suit like I I that can oftentimes
be cheesy but I like the way they did it here
where it's like he's got the full suit with
all the armor on it and then as he's like
this isn't me he takes it off and it becomes
the suit that we all know so well yeah I really
dug that yeah so this was 2015. when did the
Aquaman movie come out was it 2016 it wasn't
that long it wasn't eight years or seven years
ago find out Aquaman 2018. 2018. okay so two
years later Dean Arthur Curry my man okay
so this was close oh Sean asthma's Billy Batson
of course it was yeah you got Jerry O'Connell
Clark Kent solid yeah okay Jason MRA back
to crushing does Bruce Wayne Shemar Moore
is back I feel like he's done a cyborg before
right I think so interesting that's a good
okay Harry Lennox was black man so there you
go yeah okay was didn't he uh jump up into
the Snyder verse I think he did as Martian
Manhunter wasn't it yeah wasn't that Harry
Lennox two years later yeah uh yeah so I I
mean I I enjoyed this more than the uh the
other one in this specific series just because
it did feel like the characterizations were
a little more of a blend of this new one and
their their counterpart yeah yeah yeah this
split the difference I think pretty nice I'm
very curious where it goes with those characterizations
like forward like this voice cast this universe
this Multiverse they've built yeah totally
and yeah yeah to see as it moves forward I'm
wondering if it becomes maybe more intentionally
connected connectable or something like that
or more consistent like I'd be curious to
know as we get further into these and especially
thank you all for you know we were pretty
aware that that yeah like uh assault and Arkham
is is outside of this continuity but yeah
like within this continuity I'd be curious
to know yeah what the plans were when they
realized like okay we are going to do this
big connected sequence of movies and yeah
then how the characters are affected you know
in their portrayals by that because it is
interesting like especially yeah coming directly
out of uh Justice League War it's like if
you watch them back to back I have to feel
like the the characters would feel a bit different
yeah and also the end of Justice League War
With The Atlantis thing I thought that was
like an offensive like the end of the post-credits
scene felt like he was already he was yeah
just like coming up and he was like coming
back yeah yeah so that must be an odd thing
to back-to-back it's yeah it's an interesting
yeah I guess they they kind of loosely together
yet what he was going to be doing they're
like we didn't really think of the the overall
arch of that story when we did that post credit
scene we were just like oh we gotta establish
the atlanteans are coming and and yeah and
then why Aquaman was nowhere to be found and
this was a way better way to do it I love
like I said a few times the the two stories
coming together like this was the move also
if you've got Michael Rosenbaum you make him
Lex Luthor drift leader Michael Rosemont what
are you doing one day was he only available
one day you got the best Lex in the game in
the house ah yeah he'll get his time in the
sun James gun you bring back Rosie you put
him in that ball shave that man's head you
put him in Multiverse man if they do if anyone
should come from the TV world it's it's I
think he's the best Lex of all time you heard
me Gene Hackman oh you work out Gene he heard
you he watches he watches I love Eugene Hackman
yeah he's the best and we also got a little
John Henry iron we did that was good you called
it immediately yeah so far to hyphenate the
name you know and it's gonna be but at the
same time I was just like oh what a cool thing
and and that it doesn't have to become it's
just a guy yeah he'll he could show up later
and I'll be even more psyched if that happens
I like when they do that like World build
without having to be a thing yeah totally
yeah I dug this this was a lot of fun if you
guys enjoyed please do leave a comment let
us know what you thought uh this was up there
for me and this definitely I was a little
concerned uh with like being kind of iffy
on the characterizations of a few characters
in the first one this has me very excited
for whatever we get into next very very excited
and then I know the out of continuity Arkham
absolute July so these have been fantastic
so we would love to keep doing them so please
the best way for that to happen is for you
to like subscribe and share and notification
Bell to do YouTube things I'm out of words
uh John always a pleasure always a pleasure
sir thanks for having me with you and and
hey before we skedaddle you want to do some
Patriot Edition
Adelia Chamberlain you belong are the one
who keeps my Discord not in disarray oh in
a rake but that's called Discord so I was
playing with words there you are a champion
and we appreciate you feeling so ideal tastic
oh do good work oh yeah you just stay invested
dude you care about the fandoms she's like
the mirror of your Discord you're Aquaman
she's like hey man you gotta rise I only get
in there like twice a week but she's always
ready yeah because I'm just I got a lot to
do sometimes I'm off Planet sometimes I'm
here sometimes about other channels but Delia's
always keeping it down hell yeah that is very
much appreciated thank you Patron you're you're
our Valentine for this month collectively
all of us here at the reject Nation you're
our value this is February isn't it it is
only took me a little over a week to put that
together yeah man Black History Month and
Valentine's Day here all about love and figuring
out equality one goddamn in America figure
it out at a time I love you Delia catch you
next month foreign